what's up everyone welcome back to the
cider interview Studio at Sundance 2024
I am lucky enough to be sitting with the
team behind Pony Boy congratulations
your movie is phenomenal I'm so happy
for you all thank you so much thank you
before we get into our conversation I
have to say a special thank you to filo
our Sundance sponsor this year they are
an incredible company that's breaking
barriers by putting the power to
Greenlight movies in the hands of
creators and fans if you'd like to learn
more about check out their website
film. all right River I'm giving you the
hardest question of the bunch today hit
me with it a lot of our viewers are
going to first learn about Pony Boy
through Sundance so can you give us a
brief description of your movie yes so
it all unfolds on a cold Valentine's Day
in New Jersey and pony boy is an
intersec sex worker who has a drug deal
that goes wrong and um is needs to
Escape From the Mob on a chilling 24
hours in New Jersey you came play today
I like it that was spot on well
delivered well delivered I think that
means you'll be ready for my complicated
two-part question about taking this from
short to feature can you tell me one
thing that was really difficult about
getting the green light on the feature
version but then I also want to know
something about the short and its
reception that actually made getting the
green light
easier I think the hardest part about
getting the green light from the short
was that the pandemic happened and that
was it was really a struggle honestly
because I think in the indie film making
landscape people were really more averse
to taking risk and this the film is is
bold it's Unapologetic and at the helm
of it was me a you know a discovery
talent and I think a lot of people
passed on what they enjoyed a
well-crafted script but because I was in
the middle of it they didn't want to
take that risk because of you know the
state of the economy and the pandemic
and all that stuff
um so that was really hard because it
was like I knew that I had gold on my
hands and I think other people also
recognized it as well but you know it's
just timing um but I think what made it
easier was that the short was so beloved
by so many people and I still get people
that that I'm like You' seen the short
like why they're like because it's good
and I saw it and it's it's a standalone
film on its own right and especially
for what it did
for like culture and it's weird to be
honest about of a short film like having
some kind of cultural impact but it
really had a life of its own that when
our producers Mark and and Trevor came
involved like they they loved the short
so much and so when they saw this the
feature script they were just fully on
board short films make all the
difference I would say this about roles
in movies too there are no small roles
and short films are just as valuable as
feature films and also they can be used
as calling cards to get features off the
ground too there's so many movies at
Sundance this year that are coming in
here that got their feature opportunity
because their short exists yeah I love
it I love it so you were a co-director
on the short here you hand the directing
Reigns over to eston what was it about
him that gave you the confidence that
you know this is someone I can hand my
baby to in a sense I mean eson is just
the sweetest human being he he was like
our our our sweet dad that like just he
he saw me and understood me on multiple
levels not just as an artist but as a
human we spent some time in New Jersey
before um we went into production just
getting to know each other and I was
like this this guy just not only on a
technical stylistic and visual um
Mastery over the craft he also had the
ability to have deep compassion for not
only the cast but every crew member like
everyone just loves him and I think that
love when it permeates when it starts
from the top it just permeates all
throughout and I just knew from the way
he was able to handle and and resonate
so much with different aspects of the
story um that he was the right person
yeah all right eston for you now when
you jump into a project like this what
kind of convinces you that you know you
have the skill set to do River's Vision
justice but but also what separates you
from the other directors what did you
think you could bring to this film as a
director that maybe some others out
there couldn't I mean I read this script
and it was phenomenal it was like I read
it in one go um so at the story level it
was always there but I did take you know
a minute to consider am I the right
person for this um task because I'm I'm
not queer I'm not intersex but I am an
immigrant and that is the lens that I
wanted to use to tell this story as a
first generation
immigrant you kind of come to this
country or wherever else that you're
moving with a set of like inherited
values belief systems religion and at
some point you have to reckon with that
doesn't make sense for you to continue
that or do you adopt a new identity a
new set of beliefs and that to me felt
like a universal story that hit very
close to home um and that's when I was
like I'll do everything to make this a
badass movie and then because the story
takes place so much inside of pony boy's
head uh I love that in movies you know
movies that make us dream uh that we can
really Flex with all the Cinematic
language uh using music and just
different cinematic styles to create a a
a full colorful world it's it's it's a
world on its own so it's I mean I
couldn't say no can you give us a
specific example of a technique you use
to make uh Pony Boy internal World feel
accessible to the
audience um I feel like the specificity
of the sequences um where Pony Boy
remembers like um even though they're
traumatic moments with family they feel
specific in the language and the culture
and the iconography that we show um and
the visual language that we use is so
different contrast with the rest of the
movie and so like it it pulls you in
makes you pay attention um and it feels
playful too like it doesn't it doesn't
Revel in tragedy it wants you to you
know connect with the character and not
feel pity but empathy you know very
successful in that respect this is my
favorite type of question to ask I want
all of you to talk about River cuz this
is this is your first time leading a
feature film your first time writing a
feature film your first time producing a
feature film and if you want more of
those opportunities I have a very good
feeling they're going to be out there
for you so can you each name something
about River as like a scene partner
collaborator a leader on set that you're
excited for more artists to get to
experience when they work with them in
the future I got something I want to
say say it h say l
um if you want a master class
in if in in the
lesson of if you
want something done you got to do it
yourself look no further than riverg
I watched
River not from the very beginning but
maybe like toward the end of the
beginning of the
journey I've watched River um from the
end of the beginning
on actually literally take something
that they wanted to do they wanted to
create they wanted to
become and that they wanted to to
see and they made it happen I mean I've
been talking about the things that I
want to make with so much passion for
like six
years
and the same time that I heard that
River wanted to do something was the
same time that I heard it was getting
done and that is incredibly inspiring to
me and I think it's
really important for people to be able
to recognize when somebody has power
before they have power and the ways that
we're used to associating power in this
industry for
example you know you got to be one of
the show on a top you know you got to
have the you know this this and this and
that and River literally was
like brought everything together and
told an incredibly powerful sorry I'm
taking up too much time uh
story storydream slre life
experience that we can all relate to or
that many people can relate to who
aren't intersex and they told it from
The Narrative and perspective of an
intersex person and I think that's so
brilliant and
important and
Powerful um nobody a lot of people don't
even know that intersex folks
exist um and a lot of people only know
how to identify intersex people through
language that is outdated for example
hermaphodite
and um there's so many different terms
that are derogatory that people may be
familiar with in association to intersex
people but I think River brought so much
Humanity to um an experience that people
have TR that that people are still
delegitimizing um as less than human and
um less deserving of of autonomy and and
fully just
like put all of their potions together
and
made such a brilliant film and they
managed to create an
intersection
h
um it wasn't supposed to be that funny
sorry with a narrative about um with a
with an they made an
intersection in their story with a a a
trans person's experience as well and
like sort of built a scenario where um
this intersex person is depending on
this trans person who's so resourced but
then they're they're and then they're
both walking away from the situation
with some something that they need um
and that the trans person didn't know
that they needed and and this is a
historic film for so many reasons but
also I'm deeply inspired and I hope that
people don't take for granted this
opportunity to learn and feel and
experience something that exists outside
of themselves also like seeing everybody
talk
about what this film film means to
them and what it means for them to be a
part of it has been the each and every
person involved that has spoken about it
I've
seen speak so emotionally and so deeply
about their relationships to their
characters and
also just this film and I can't
highlight enough
how in credible it is to see the
opportunity that
River has made for people to feel
deeply behind the camera in front of the
camera in the
audience in the
story and
also I don't know River managed to put
together a really beautiful group of
people who are just really beautiful
people just and and and I and I want
want to be a part of more of that in
film and TV and I
almost
quit because I didn't have enough of
those experiences and River
reignited the
love I know y'all getting tired but
River reignited the love for art and
film making and creativity for me and I
know that they're going to do that for
so for so many more people so yeah I
took my time in talking about
River and their incredible cast my
colleagues because this is a
historic this is a historic
project
um and I wanted to put as much energy as
I could in in really trying to explain
what I wanted to say so thank you it's
important thing to explain it's a
beautiful
answer who can top that no it's not a
competition yeah there's no I think
topping that is the language um uh I
mean I would just watching India just
now uh was incredible and just so many
reasons that you just stated um uh were
woven into that watching you for me
watching you speak about River watching
you speak about what this experience
meant to you um watching you speak so
eloquently and emotionally um about how
it reignited a love for you watching
Victoria
um like I mean like literally
um come to tears and answering questions
about her character today you know um
watching estabon last night address uh
uh in such a vulnerable way your
insecurities at first your doubts that
you had of like am I the right person
right and you get an emotional last
night and everything it is really
profound and special um that we all do
feel this way about this piece that we
are a part of you know and that is like
real that's like as authentic as it gets
you know what I mean and so we're all
just I think very on the same page and
just so presently aware of that and what
this means in this moment and what this
means in this moment in River's life uh
and just the the gratefulness that I
feel that we all feel to be uh even a
part of that is um very true and very
true so deeply um because we all love
you so much uh I think we all fell in
love with you instantly everyone falls
in love with you instantly and that is
not an accident you are lighted uh you
are you are so special I mean I know
we're born the same year we're also both
from North Jersey you know what I mean
like we have we we I just feel like I
just connected to you so much just so
instantly but you you just you're like
that with everybody you know you radiate
and um I mean it's it's in terms of what
uh the world can expect uh from River as
an artist um I
mean this is this is what we want from
our artists isn't it uh somebody
somebody who I mean I mean your your
blood is on that page baby you know what
I mean like that's that's this story is
is so truly you to your bones you know
uh so it's just it's not like go you
know we're not going to work every day
uh uh uh yeah it's it's it's it's bigger
than that you know what I mean um
everyone just put everything into it was
just like so inspiring uh to go to get
to go and do this every day and then to
have this moment here I mean just the
couldn't be more grateful we're all
crushing this
question yeah I got a oh sorry Victoria
no go for it I was you know same like
the second that I met River I was like I
am meeting somebody that is so unique
like I have never met anybody so in
touch with their identity and so secure
and who they are even though they are in
you know the Pinnacle of breaking the
conversation towards the bigger audience
right um that takes a lot of Courage a
lot of you know introspection and um
they did that for all of us like River
challenged some things in me about my
Heritage about you know who who I am as
a latino man and it's made me grow so
much and I feel like
um this movie that we all made together
is a gift that you know it's so once in
A- lifetime thing that we get to create
and is alchemy really um and I hope that
people dig the movie and have a great
time with it because it's so [__] fun
um but also lifechanging got high hopes
that's going to be the response to this
all right Vic what you got yeah I'm like
what what does the future hold like if
people choose
to I mean like uh
what I'm
buzzing
it's yeah this has been like a really
amazing experience getting to talk about
this film a lot but like to be able to
talk about you um I mean you're an
incredible person you're incredibly um
introspective I I I I think that you
know I don't think you come towards a
sense of like security and understanding
yourself and holding all of your like
complexity as a person like that's how
you draw and paint such beautiful
pictures of such complex characters um
and I don't know I'm just so curious
like what the next story you're going to
make
is I really hope that you
can I don't know I just don't I kind of
just have the ultimate faith that you
will stay true to
yourself throughout your career and I
hope you just keep being empowered to
make exactly what you want
um yeah I mean this has been such an
amazing opportunity I'm I'm just I don't
know I just have faith and I just I
think everybody else should too and that
it's going to be Brave and Bold and
filled filled with love
cuz that's like the most important thing
like this movie has a lot of tragedy and
like suffering in it but ultimately it's
very
[Music]
um
hopeful um which I think you are
also
and yeah I I think everybody will want
to work with you as long as they can
respect you and let you do exactly what
you want to do and just Empower you to
work with the people you want to work
with and do what you want to do yeah
those answers oh what a what a beautiful
difficult to work with yeah cuz we'll
come for them because we'll come no I
I'll do the difficult
one to touch on some characters briefly
River I I love how a character can
expand when you have a different set of
creators around you so is there any new
layer to Pony Boy that you discovered
because of the collaboration that you
had with the people sitting at this
table oh my god of of course I I I I
created something on the page that I
thought I understood about the character
and that I thought I understood of
myself in the conceiving of the
character and you know with like my
acting coach or whatever but working
with the these people like they're the
most
talented
heartfelt just they kind compassionate
I and the the did I say talented like
liter I I just they took for some reason
they believed in me and believed that
despite not leading a a feature that I
could you know go head to toe with them
I mean like what like you guys are all
on seasons of television and I'm just
like hey you want to make my
movie
but like I but the collaboration of with
on each of them on all of our scenes
together it it changed my understanding
of who I am and the layers of pony boy
recognizing that I mean I always knew he
was a flawed character and a bit of an
anti-hero but I think there was
something very early on that S1 said to
me that I I thought that pony boy was a
hopeless romantic and then esan said no
I think he's a hopeful
romantic and and I think sorry I've only
ever described myself that way I've
never heard anyone ever describe anyone
maybe you are too Pony Boy I am I have't
everyone has a pony boy inside of them I
think that's the thing it's a character
that is so specific in in his Despair
and his longing and his yearning that it
becomes really Universal and and I
discovered in myself that the movie is
really about the Journey of discovering
one's belonging and Redemption and and
the ability to be okay with um the
uncertainties that life throws our way
and I think all of them made me feel
okay about this next chapter of my life
that is going to you know foreseeably be
very different than what I once knew it
to be um but I I just know that I I have
a family a new family now that we
created on Pony Boy and I'm just
thrilled to make more movies with with
them film making families make me so
happy I could keep I'm getting a firm
wrapup sign now I could keep you here
all day movie is phenomenal a truly
something special and before I even ever
saw any of your work and we had that
conversation just like you just exude
such confidence and it's infectious and
I have a very good feeling I know with
certainty it's going to inspire a lot of
people out there so
congratulations never change keep
bringing your stories to the screen
thank you all so much for being
everybody out there keep an eye out for
Pony Boy big thanks to fil for
sponsoring our Sundance studio and we'll
be back soon with more interviews pony
boy is going to win
everything